well we're talking about uh airstrikes
and whether the uk will join in with the
united states
or not but both countries saying they
haven't really got a coherent strategy
together for dealing with islamic states
how do you think we get towards that
point well i hope that
that's a subject that's going to be
discussed in the very fortuitously time
meeting of of the nato alliance
because we certainly do need to have a
strategy i think one is beginning to
emerge
uh clearly in the existing action of the
united states
in providing logistical and not only
justical but also military support to
the peshmerga
i think the issue is the following that
not only
does isis or ice or the islamic state
already
pose a threat in terms of the number of
people
who are actually going to join it but
increasingly if these people
are allowed to institutionalize their
presence that's to say
in effect form uh however governed a
state on the ground
the threat to us is going to be very
much greater than it already is
and really we will then be at a much
more critical level of
of uh insecurity so it's very important
i think it's increasingly important now
that we have to
prevent we have to disrupt the creation
of this state
so it does and as your question to me
implied
i think increasingly pose the question
of how much military action
what kind of military action are we
going to take
or are we western countries going to
take i would be against the united
kingdom
going it alone just with the united
states i want to see
a much broader coalition form itself to
deal with this issue
but on that issue of uh of dealing and
trying to destroy trying to crush
islamic state
uh it's not lose lose though because if
that happens if you
kick over the ants nest or whatever
analogy you want to go for the
the feeling is is of course they're
going to go somewhere and
many of those people with british
passports will come back to these shores
well they may some of them may come back
to these shores others will disperse i
suppose and they will disperse into
probably back into syria where a lot of
them have come from possibly into other
places but i think that
that that risk is not one that we can
use as an alibi for not actually taking
action to prevent the
institutionalization
of what is an abhorrent form of of
or political organization and one which
is a threat not only to this country and
to our to our allies but actually to the
region as a whole
uh so i think that that is it's
certainly a risk but it's one we have to
take and we will have to deal with the
consequences of that as they arise
and what do you make of the with the
so-called toughening of anti-terror
powers
in this country to deal with the
possibility
of that threat have things really
changed have we really toughened up the
regime
i think that to me personally i think
that we have a very
considerable panoply of powers in
government to deal with this
uh i think the removal of passports is
one that certainly
the police ought to be able to use much
more quickly than simply through
the home secretary's uh royal
prerogative for the removal of passports
uh i think the measures that are
directed at disrupting the flow of
people
are apt and can be implemented quickly i
think the other measures that have been
enunciated i think
no one can think about those personally
i'm in favor on the whole though of
really
rigorous implementation of the of
existing powers
and they do include uh really tight
control of our borders
and that has yet to be complete you know
not all the
immigration controls and immigration
controls that we can and should have in
place
are yet fully fully implemented and
that's going to be a very very important
part i think of the disruption that we
need to
we need to undertake the prevent program
that's to say
radically de-radicalizing and preventing
radicalization
also very important but obviously a much
longer term